wang dan est aujourd'hui un des ténors
de l'opposition à l'extérieur de la
chine
nous nous sommes rencontrés il y a
trente ans juste avant le massacre du 4
juin 1989 il était un des principaux
leaders du printemps de pékin
il n'avait que 20 ans et il était prêt à
tout pour démocratiser la chine ne te ce
que je fais c'est pour le bien du pays
je ne dois pas avoir peur m'at-il dit à
l'époque je coure un risque la prison
peut-être mais l'histoire me donnera
raison je sais j'ai étudié l'histoire
wang dan a été arrêté un mois après
l'intervention brutale de l'armée
il a passé sept ans en prison sous la
pression internationale les autorités
l'ont libéré exilé aux états unis
il n'a jamais pu revenir dans son pays
natal la soul et mairie accueil humain
la prison oui c'est la limite que
j'avais imaginé jamais on n'aurait pensé
de se faire tirer dessus une dit wang
dan en marge d'une conférence de presse
qui lance la journée de commémoration
ici à washington tu do you feel intrus
en aujourd'hui directeur du tout nouveau
dialogue china qui vise à unir
l'opposition au régime de pékin
il reste combatif trois niveaux et au
fight for des mauves les chinois vont se
battre pour la démocratisation
même si ce n'est pas une majorité mais
ils vont le faire dit il
quand je lui demande s'il pense voir une
chine démocratique de son vivant il
répond à un double but des vracs je ne
crois pas je n'ai aucun espoir ainsi
jean ping
juste avant de quitter pour le prochain
événement
il insiste sur le rôle de l'occident
tous les pays occidentaux y compris le
canada doit faire quelque chose pour
avancer la démocratie en chine
lance-t-il sinon elle n'avancera jamais
devant le capitole une cérémonie à la
mémoire des victimes de tiananmen
il est un des principaux orateurs et
c'est celle qu'on considère comme la
femme la plus puissante des états unis
la leader de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi qui vient
dévoiler la statue de l'homme qui a
arrêté les chars d'assaut sur tiananmen
elle profite de l'événement pour saluer
chaleureusement wang dan elle est une
amie de longue date notre plus grand
soutien aux états unis elles nous aident
à promouvoir la démocratie en chine
détenteur d'un doctorat en histoire de
l'université de hong kong
wang dan a refait sa vie aux états unis
mais la chine lui manque
il pense que la guerre commerciale menée
contre la chine par l'actuelle
administration de son pays d'adoption ne
suffira pas et il espère que le
sacrifice de ceux qui sont tombés sur
tiananmen et des milliers des
prisonniers politiques actuelles n'aura
pas été en vain il y à 30 ans à pékin
quelques jours avant l'intervention de
l'armée
ils avaient appelé les étudiants à
rentrer sur les campus
il ne s'agit plus de descendre dans les
rues croyait-il il faut établir la
démocratie à l'université légaliser
l'association étudiante fonder une radio
un journal mais ne l'ont pas écouté et
ont payé de leur vie
hand stade là je comprends qu'ils ne
m'ont pas écouté il y a trente ans les
autorités n'ont répondu à aucune de nos
demandes
alors comment je pouvais les persuader
la journée de commémoration se poursuit
et l'ex leader étudiant se dirige vers
un autre rassemblement
la cimade lieu d'ici 20 ans si la
croissance économique et militaire
continue la chine sera une menace
semblable au fascisme et ce sera
terrible
tout comme il ya trente ans - gaudin est
sûr de la justesse de son combat ici
alexandra chaps qu'à radio-canada
washington